afghanistan's president ashraf ghani has
gone he's left the country as taliban
leaders push for what they say is a
peaceful transfer of power in kabul
hours earlier mr ghani delivered a
televised message promising to take
responsibility for the security of the
people of kabul
there is a clear need that the national
directorate of security alongside the
police and the afghan army take
responsibility for the security of all
citizens i have asked the defense
minister and the interior minister to
convey that message it is our
responsibility and god willing we will
carry that out in the best possible
manner anyone who is disturbing the law
and order or things of looting should be
confronted with full force
well taliban fighters have been ordered
to wait on the outskirts of the capital
despite no threat of imminent attack
there are worries on the streets of
kabul about what the taliban's return
will mean for the people of kabul
foreign embassies are evacuating their
staff with helicopters going between
those buildings and the airport u.s
officials are now working from that
airport terminal while some eu staff
have moved to a safer quotes undisclosed
location
overshadowed by its brutal rule of the
past the taliban is offering
reassurances about the kind of
government it will lead it says women's
rights will be respected and those
people who worked for the government
will be offered an amnesty live now to
kabul and our correspondent rob mcbride
so he decided to go i guess we'll hear
him at some point saying for the greater
good of the country rob
yeah it's quite uh quite a shock i mean
we've been expecting all day that to see
uh developments with regard to this
transition of power the the story has
been so far that he has been held up in
the presidential palace busy in
negotiations with his own people and of
course with the negotiating teams
including the taliban in doha about an
acceptable uh transition which
everybody i think by now accepts that
would not necessarily involve him being
involved certainly the taliban wouldn't
want to be a part of any new
administration with ashraf ghani but the
shock has come that he has actually left
the country all together and is uh now
in taijikistan so it does
beg the question where is this
transition agreement up to is even is
there is there a transition agreement
for negotiators in doha to uh to agree
to to consider
so it really
adds to the uncertainty as we get into
this sunday evening here in kabul we
know what i can tell you what we do know
we know that most of the country is in
the control of the taliban right now
kabul is surrounded and the big question
is who actually is in charge of kabul
itself it has to be said that yes it's
very tense here
there is an uneasy tension but things do
remain thankfully relatively calm on the
streets the police and the army are on
the streets people are moving about uh
this evening uh so but there are
concerns i mean we've had in the uh
taking of the provinces and the area
around uh kabul again more prisons being
opened this has been something that
we've seen throughout this uh the
conflict in recent weeks uh that as the
taliban have advanced a number of
prisons have been breached and prisoners
allowed allowed out there was a large
prison near bagram air base this was the
former base for us and nato forces that
prison contained a number of isil
prisoners that prison was overtaken the
doors were opened there's another prison
this is policy this is the prison that
serves the kabul region uh with many
more criminals there or people serving
time again the doors were open of that
prison so there is a certain amount of
unease in the capital this evening
nonetheless the taliban has insisted
that its fighters stay on the outskirts
they do not go in they have stress they
do not want to see bloodshed there
should be a peaceful transition of power
and as we've heard
during the day from both the ministers
of the interior and also the defence
minister for afghanistan they too have a
guaranteed that there will be security
here in the capital and i guess the
people of afghanistan as well as the
outside world rob and the region indeed
we need to know the makeup or the nature
of this interim administration
government
or council and i suppose that's the
explanation behind a taliban delegation
reportedly coming back to qatar because
if they behave like politicians
in their minds that's clear isn't it in
their minds they maintain some semblance
of credibility and accountability
because they're kind of behaving like
politicians they're not behaving like
warlords
yeah they have to do that i think to get
that acceptance uh especially from the
international community because of
course people as soon as you mention
taliban will be thinking about a taliban
of administration of the late 90s and
through till 2000
2001 which does fill many people with
dread you talk to people here in the
streets of kabul uh certainly people who
remember that time they remember it with
a with a
a definite sense of dread uh with some
very awful memories of that time and
despite assurances from the taliban that
there are guarantees now for women's
rights for the education of girls and so
on there are still very deep concerns in
fact when we were out in the streets
earlier this sunday and we started to
get notification that the taliban had in
fact approached the outskirts of the
city and that some fighters were being
reported some some of it erroneously
there was uh some scam messages going
around that there were talifan fighters
walking around inside the city which
wasn't the case but it does give you a
sense of the nervousness here about
about the name taliban that people were
concerned uh and uh that when you talk
to people uh there is a certain that
many people don't want to see a return
of that especially in cosmopolitan parts
like like kabul but there is an
acceptance also from people that given
their gains in recent years recent
months and now what's happened at the
moment that certainly they will be very
a very uh part and parcel of a future
administration there is an acceptance
until recently people were talking about
yes we have to share power with the
taliban that was until a couple of days
ago but given the predominance now and
the dominant dominant
the dominance of the taliban in the
country you have to ask yourself what
kind of power sharing the taliban is
going to share power with whom it does
seem as though they have the upper hand
in any negotiations that follow from
here rob you'll keep us posted i'm sure
in the meantime thank you so much rob
mcbride our correspondent there uh
reporting on that developing aspect out
of kabul well as we've been telling you
the us has been relocating its embassy
staff as the taliban encircled the city
the secretary of state anthony blinken
says core staff will be moved to a safer
location
we're moving people out of the embassy
to a location at the airport that's
happening right now uh my job my number
one priority is the safety and security
of our people uh and we've adjusted uh
along the way as i said we started an
ordered departure from our mississippi
way back at the end of april
and we've done that systematically
progressively and we've adjusted
depending on what was actually happening
on the ground and that's exactly what
we're doing now so if no american is in
the embassy we've essentially closed the
embassy it sounds like you don't want to
say no we're going to have a yeah we're
going to have we're going to have our
core diplomatic presence
and in effect an embassy at a location
at the airport
heidi joe castro following that story
for us out of the bureau in washington
uh heidi yes clearly the u.s
administration says this is not saigon
light
but u.s embassy staff being ferried
around on helicopters and getting out as
quickly as they possibly can doesn't
look like a huge success story
that's right peter and you heard the
strained messaging from antholy antony
lincoln the u.s secretary of state this
morning essentially confirming that the
u.s embassy in kabul will no longer have
personnel essentially there will be a
small embassy within the airport
his words with that core group of
diplomats who will work to continue
processing visas for those
afghans who aided american troops and
are now trying to flee the country he
also said that the president's focus
remains foremost on the safety of
getting out those american civilians and
diplomats and pushing back on criticism
coming also from members
from u.s politics including republicans
have called this a disaster that was
preventable
anthony blanken saying that the u.s had
accomplished its mission in afghanistan
in its 20-year war in having prevented
another 9 11 like
terrorist attack stemming from
afghanistan and that it simply is no
longer in the u.s interest to remain in
the country he also did issue a stark
warning to the taliban saying that any
interference
in this evacuation effort with u.s
personnel would be met with decisive and
a decisive and swift response coming
from those 5 000 u.s troops who were
quickly deployed a thousand of whom were
quickly redeployed back into afghanistan
when the situation rapidly deteriorated
but of course there is still much
concern much criticism uh stemming
toward the byte administration uh that
why didn't they see this coming
apparently they had been given uh bad
intelligence that it would take
somewhere around 18 months for the
taliban to capture the country now as
that is happening before the very eyes
in just weeks the question is why didn't
they see this coming and could this have
been prevented heidi thank you very much
heidi jo castro there in washington
suhail shaheen is the international
media spokesman for the taliban he says
fighters have taken most cities
surrounding the capital but have not
entered kabul as yet
peaceful uh
transfer is very important because if
there is a fighting there's
the problem the power their properties
will be will be damaged the people will
be harmed which we do not want
that so it is very important for that
and the other thing is about future
government for that we are ready to talk
we do not see surrender the the summer
the the forces they have joined us we
say they have stopped fighting and they
have joined us
and all provinces in all majority of the
provinces of afghanistan they have
joined the forces and they have attended
or they come with their weapons and
everything and they they are their names
registered uh so there were proper
steps will be taken in future for uh
for how they will be
invaded in the government we will be
there we'll see
we will be waiting what i said the
peaceful trust
for peaceful transfer we will see
we will see that in in future but our uh
policy and our intention is that our
forces will
wait at the gate of the kabul until
we we are we sort of a peaceful transfer
of the city
well if you've been following the events
in kabul city kabul province and
broadly speaking afghanistan you'll know
that events have been moving very
quickly day to day events are moving
hour to hour now the taliban said
on record they said publicly they said
in an interview with this channel that
they would not tell their fighters to
enter
kabul city they have rescinded that
because they say that the afghan
security forces have in effect turned
tail and left or they have begun the
process of leaving or standing
themselves down from their jobs that
they're rostered rotate through a
taliban spokesman telling the reuters
news agency that they have now ordered
their fighters to enter kabul to prevent
looting that's all we know on that
developing aspect
of this story we'll get you more on that
just as soon as we can our correspondent
mohammad jam june reporting extensively
of course on the long-running talks here
in doha between the taliban and the
afghan government he's keeping his
company here in the studio ashraf ghani
has gone how does that impact the
discussions that we think might even
kick off again
refresh discussions tomorrow in doha at
the moment peter a lot of confusion as
to what exactly the agenda is going to
be what we know is that there is a
a delegation of afghan government
negotiators that is on route
they are expected to be in doha tomorrow
what's not known is who exactly is
heading that team of negotiators there's
been some speculation that perhaps it's
a new team a team that could start off
with a fresh slate with the uh with
their counterparts members of the
taliban delegation uh there's other
speculation that says that it's dr abdul
abdullah he's the head of the high
reconciliation council in afghanistan
and the fact that there is so much
confusion as to what exactly is
happening the fact that even members of
some of these delegations aren't quite
sure what is going to happen tomorrow
really shows you
the chaotic nature of what's going on
right now last week we covered three
days of afghan peace talks here in doha
the diplomats who were all here a lot of
them special envoys for afghanistan
they all wanted to see a way to put the
intra-afghan peace process back on track
the last time there was a meeting of the
intra-afghan peace dialogue was in
mid-july this is a process that was
initiated here in doha last september
and it really ran out of momentum and
one of the reasons it ran out of
momentum was because
people didn't have leverage over the
taliban because the taliban was already
starting to gain ground even in mid-july
so last week you had three days of talks
really what the diplomats wanted was to
be able to come up with some kind of
joint statement in which they offered a
pathway forward to try to get the
inter-afghan peace process back on track
that didn't happen what you got was a
statement at the end of it
you know
asking people to cease violence saying
that any government seized by force by
the taliban would not be recognized
internationally but not much else and so
that made people wonder what exactly is
going to happen next now we know also is
that the u.s special envoy for
afghanistan's almightzad has remained in
doha since the close of those talks so
it seems as though there was a lot of
behind the scenes meetings behind closed
doors but we don't yet know what it's
going to lead to going forward
but there is a chasm isn't there that
there's a big distance between what the
taliban are prepared to accept because
they've been in the ascendancy for
several weeks months now right and what
whatever it is that the the remnants of
whatever's left of the afghan government
can bring to that process because it
wasn't lost on anyone at the beginning
of the entire process going back to
september that you're talking about
right that the qataris were talking to
the taliban but the taliban were saying
uh anyone from the government no forget
it proximity talks yes maybe you can
ping pong around with messages but we're
not sitting down with them so they were
never sort of fully engaged in the
process because the taliban wouldn't
allow it that's right and you know that
kind of goes
last week there was an interesting day
the second day of talks there were
meetings on the sidelines of these
international talks and the meetings
were held by the extended troika
countries that's russia that's the us
that's china and pakistan these are
countries it's a moscow-initiated group
these are countries that meet
intermittently uh to try to consult on
how to get the peace process back on
track in afghanistan and at this troika
meeting you had both the taliban in one
session and then the afghan negotiators
the government negotiation another
session give their plans on how the
peace process could go forward the
afghan government delegation said that
they would accept a mediator the taliban
delegation said they would not accept a
mediator so again really at loggerheads
and the fact is
you can't really find common ground so
even then when you couldn't find common
ground that was before kabul was
encircled by the taliban how exactly are
you going to find common ground right
now how does this process go forward
nobody really knows at this hour mohamed
thank you so much